It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢忙碌时，我的连接依然稳固。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是个难得的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. For many years, attention deficit hyperactivity disorder, or ADHD, was seen as a disorder of childhood. But in recent years, an increasing number of adults have been diagnosed with it as well. In 2023, more than 15.5 million U.S. adults said they had ADHD, and about half of those were diagnosed as adults, according to data from the National Center for Health Statistics. Now, as public awareness has grown, more people are coming forward to be tested, and researchers and mental health practitioners are developing new guidelines for diagnosing and treating adult
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不受数据流量降速限制。多年来，注意力缺陷多动障碍（ADHD）一直被视为一种儿童疾病。但近年来，越来越多的成年人也被诊断出患有此病。根据美国国家卫生统计中心的数据，2023 年，超过 1550 万美国成年人表示自己患有 ADHD，其中约有一半是在成年后才被诊断出来的。现在，随着公众意识的提高，越来越多的人主动寻求检测，研究人员和心理健康从业者也正在制定诊断和治疗成人的新指南。
ADHD. So what's driving the rise in adult diagnoses? Is ADHD becoming more common, or is it just recognized more often? How do the symptoms differ between adults and children? What treatments are available for adults with ADHD? How does ADHD affect people's lives? in adulthood, from relationships to work to physical health. And if you suspect you might have ADHD,
ADHD。那么，是什么推动了成人诊断率的上升？是 ADHD 变得更普遍了，还是仅仅因为被识别的频率更高了？成人和儿童的症状有何不同？有哪些针对成人 ADHD 的治疗方法？ADHD 如何影响人们的成年生活，从人际关系到工作再到身体健康？如果你怀疑自己可能患有 ADHD，
where can you go for diagnosis and support? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Russell Ramsey, the founding co-director of the Penn Adult ADHD
你可以去哪里寻求诊断和支持？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人 Kim Mills。我今天的嘉宾是宾夕法尼亚大学佩雷尔曼医学院成人 ADHD 治疗与研究项目的创始联合主任 Russell Ramsey 博士，他已于 2023 年退休。他撰写了大量同行评审的科学文章和六本书，包括美国心理学会出版的《重新思考成人 ADHD：帮助客户将意图转化为行动》（Rethinking Adult ADHD: Helping Clients Turn Intentions into Actions），以及《成人 ADHD 与焦虑工作手册：管理压力、寻找专注力并重获生活的认知行为疗法技能》（The Adult ADHD and Anxiety Workbook: Cognitive Behavioral Therapy Skills to Manage Stress, Find Focus, and Reclaim Your Life）。自学术界退休后，Ramsey 博士已转向远程心理学，
Treatment and Research Program at the University of Pennsylvania. Daniel Perlman School of Medicine, from which he retired in 2023. He's authored numerous peer-reviewed scientific articles and six books, including the APA book, Rethinking Adult ADHD, helping clients turn intentions into actions, and the Adult ADHD and Anxiety Workbook, Cognitive Behavioral Therapy Skills to Manage Stress, Find Focus, and Reclaim Your Life. Since retiring from academia, Dr. Ramsey has transitioned to a telepsychology,
专门治疗 ADHD 患者。Ramsey 博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。Kim，很高兴也很荣幸能在这里与您交流。那么，让我们从我在介绍中提出的第一个问题开始。您认为是什么导致了成人 ADHD 诊断率的上升？是它变得更普遍了，还是人们只是对此有了更多的了解？你知道吗？正如我的一位同事所说，几年前并没有关于“这些患有 ADHD 的成年人都去哪了”的头条新闻。
practice treating patients with ADHD. Dr. Amsi, thank you for joining me today. Kim, it's a pleasure and an honor to be here with you. Well, let's start with the first question I posed in the introduction. What do you think is causing the rise in adult ADHD diagnoses? Is it becoming more common or are people just becoming more aware of it? You know what? As one of my colleagues said, there were no headlines years ago about where are all these adults
所以，我认为第一个答案，很大程度上是一种“纠偏”。我认为特别是在疫情和封锁期间，随着日常生活支柱的丧失——去学校、去工作，必须在家里进行自我组织，无论是孩子在家学习还是成年人在家工作——正如我的一位客户所说，现在全世界终于开始理解我生命中的每一天是什么样子了，那种试图制造动力和结构的感觉。所以，很大一部分原因是纠偏。而且我还认为，随着这一点以及疫情期间对心理健康问题日益重视和严肃对待，
with ADHD? So part of it, I think the first answer, a large part of it is a correction. And I think especially with the pandemic and lockdown, with the loss of the scaffolding of everyday life going to school, going to work, having to self-organize at home, both children learning at home and adults working from home, as one of my clients said, now the world is getting to understand what every day of my life has been like for me, trying to manufacture this motivation and the structure. So a big part of it is a correct. direction. And I also think with that and the increased attention and seriousness with which
我认为这让更多人开始谈论它。关于 ADHD 的可靠信息正在帮助许多人寻求成人 ADHD 的评估和治疗。随着各州对远程心理学和跨州执业许可限制的放宽，我认为这为像我这样熟悉成人 ADHD 诊断和治疗的人提供了更多的接触机会。成人 ADHD 的症状是什么样的？我想我们对孩子的情况有个概念，比如他们无法集中注意力，在课堂上表现出捣乱行为等等。我想我们可能有那种印象，但在成年人身上是如何表现的呢？它与儿童的情况有何不同？
mental health issues were addressed over the pandemic, I think it got more people talking about it. And the credible information out there with ADHD was helping a lot of people to seek out assessment and treatment for adult ADHD. And with the loosening of the state-by-state licensing restrictions for telepsychology and cross-state practice, I think it gave greater access to people like myself who are familiar with the diagnosis and treatment of adult ADHD. What do ADHD symptoms look like in adults? I think we have an idea of what it's like for kids where they can't focus, they act out in classrooms, things like that. I think we may have that image, but how does it present in adults? How is it different from what happens with kids?
没错。你知道吗？诊断标准与《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM，现为 DSM-5-TR）中的 18 个症状完全相同。最持续的症状是注意力不集中，即易分心、难以维持、启动和保持专注，以及在分心后难以回到正轨。每个人都会分心，但 ADHD 患者在重新投入到之前的专注点时会感到困难。有趣的是，冲动性相对持续，但在成年人身上表现不同。在儿童身上，它可能是上课时冲动地插话、不按顺序发言等。成年人也可能插话或在谈话中抢话，以及表现为冲动决策、冲动消费，而拖延症的核心特征
Right. You know what? The criteria are the exact same 18 symptoms in the DSM, now the DSM-5-TR. And the most persistent symptoms are the inattentive symptoms, the distractability, the difficulty sustaining, initiating, and sustaining focus, and getting back on track after distraction. Everybody can get distracted, but individuals with ADHD have a hard time re-engaging and whatever the focus was. Interestingly, impulsivity is relatively persistent, but it looks different in adults, whereas with children, it might be impulsively speaking out in school, speaking out of turn, if you will. Grownups can still speak out of turn or overtalk situations, as well as impulsive decision-making, impulsive spending, and a core feature.
对每个人来说都是冲动。我知道我应该做这件事，但我还是先做一会儿别的事吧。这就是冲动。但我们通常不会这样想，因为它非常微妙，但它仍然表现为偏离正轨并追随冲动。第三大症状是多动，这在成人 ADHD 患者身上通常更加内化，表现为一种内在的躁动感，可能不会表现为起身走动或爬上椅子，但在通常合理的时间长度内，比如在工作会议或其他类似场合，许多成人 ADHD 患者会开始坐立不安、抖腿，或者脚部晃动。也许你的一些听众现在听我说话时，也在坐立不安，寻找别的事情做。
of procrastination for everybody is impulsivity. I know I should be doing this, but let me just do this for a minute. That's impulsivity. But we don't think about it because it's very subtle, but it's still moving off and following the impulse. And the third of the big three, the hyperactivity, this generally gets more internalized for adults with ADHD and internal sense of restlessness that may not show up in terms of getting up, moving around, obviously climbing on a chair, but generally within reasonable lengths of time, such as a work meeting or something like that, many adults with ADHD will start to fidget around, tap their foot, maybe wagging their foot a bit. Maybe some of your listeners right now listening to me are fidgeting around looking for something else to do.
有趣的是，关于女性成人 ADHD 的一种看法是，她们在注意力不集中型表现中占比过高，而没有多动表现。但一些较新的综述发现，实际上混合型表现（即注意力不集中和多动同时存在）的比例中，女性表现出的冲动和多动水平与男性大致相同，只是表现方式不同。事实上，一项针对儿童的研究发现，女孩和男孩表现出相同的行为，但在女孩身上并没有像在男孩身上那样被归类为多动和冲动，尽管独立评估员发现
And interestingly, one of the, I'd say the perceptions, of ADHD and adulthood for women was that they were overrepresented of in the inattentive presentation without the hyperactivity. But some more recent reviews are finding that actually the rates of the combined presentation, both the inattention and the hyperactivity, women actually manifest roughly the same levels of impulsivity and hyperactivity as males, but it's just manifesting in different ways. And in fact, one review looking at children, girls versus boys manifesting the same behaviors, it did not get categorized as hyperactivity and impulsivity in girls as much as it was in boys, even though independent raters were finding
它们的行为几乎是一样的。因此，在症状的记录和归因上存在一些性别差异。不出所料，根据美国疾病控制与预防中心（CDC）关于美国成人 ADHD 患病率的最新数据，报告显示一半的 ADHD 患者是在成年后（18 岁或以后）被识别出来的，而在这一群体中，61% 是女性。所以，这又是另一种正在发生的“纠偏”，即女性的成人诊断通常来得较晚，尽管随着意识的提高，这种情况可能正在改变。那么，是因为女孩行为与男孩行为的刻板印象，导致我们在她们年幼时错过了诊断吗？我认为这在很大程度上是事实，尽管我认为，至少对于成年人来说，回到
it about the same behavior. So there are some gender differences in how the symptoms were noted and attributed, and no surprise, with recent CDC data about the prevalence of adult ADHD in United States, which reported that half of individuals with ADHD have been identified in adulthood, 18 years old or later, and of that group, 61% were females. So that's another correction going on that the diagnosis in adults for women generally comes later, even though that may be changing now with the increased awareness. So do we miss it when they're younger because of the stereotypes for girl behavior versus boy behavior? I'd say that's to a large degree true, even though I think, at least with adults, going back to
多年前临床转诊的儿童病例，男孩与女孩的比例约为 10 比 1。现在到了成年期，差异约为 1.5 比 1。因此，随着对不同表现形式的理解加深，有一点需要记住：ADHD 不是由环境引起的，但它肯定受环境影响。例如，需要持续注意力、长时间工作而没有休息或某种认可、奖励等环境，对成人 ADHD 患者来说更困难。但可能存在其他情况，比如团队合作、动手工作，那里有很多休息时间
children, for clinic referred children years ago, it was about a 10 to one boy to girl ratio. Now with adulthood, the differential is about one and a half to one, male to female. So with the increased understanding of the different manifestations, and one of the things to remember, ADHD is not caused by the environment, but it is certainly bound in the environment. Like different settings requiring sustained attention, working on tasks for a long time without breaks or some sort of acknowledgement or reward or something like that, are more difficult for adults with ADHD. But there might be other situations with working in teams, working hands-on work, where there's a lot of breaks
或者有更及时的反馈或提醒来保持任务进度，在这些情况下，ADHD 患者可以做得很好，甚至表现出色。如果人们在成年后被诊断出患有 ADHD，这是否意味着他们一直都有这种病但未被诊断，还是它可能在以后的生活中发展出来？ADHD 被认为是一种神经发育综合征。因此，通常情况下，即使某人在成年后才被识别，成人诊断的一部分也是确认童年时期症状的出现。你不必在之前达到诊断水平或被诊断过。
or more immediate feedback or reminders to stay on task, there are situations where individuals with ADHD can do quite well if not thrive. If people are diagnosed with ADHD as adults, does it mean that they've always had it and it wasn't diagnosed or can it develop later in life? ADHD is concerted a neurodevelopmental syndrome. And so it is generally, even if somebody is late identified in adults, part of the adult diagnosis is confirming childhood onset of symptoms. You don't have to have the diagnostic levels or have been diagnosed before.
这不是诊断的要求，但评估的一部分是根据手册确认症状是否在 12 岁之前出现。现在，我遵循 DSM 标准。然而，有一些证据表明，16 岁可能是一个更好的标记，因为 12 岁会错过那些初中阶段，因为随着生理年龄的增长，人们对不同程度的自我调节有发育期望。现在，问题的另一部分是，它是否可以在后期从头发展？几年前，有很多研究探讨了成人发作型 ADHD 的可能性。
That is not a requirement of the diagnosis, but part of the evaluation is confirming by the book whether there was symptom emergence, many symptoms showing up before age 12. Now, I follow DSM. However, there's some evidence to say that 16 years old, is probably a better marker because the 12-year-old, it misses those middle school years where there's a developmental expectation for different levels of self-regulation with increased chronological age. Now, another part of the question was, can it develop de novo later? And a few years back, there were a lot of studies looking at the potential for adult onset ADHD.
这与“晚期识别”不同。晚期识别是指，是的，你童年时就有症状，但你顺利完成了学业，也许表现平平，也许没有，但症状持续存在并导致了日益严重的困难。现在你 21、25、35、55 岁了，它造成了损害，所以我们可以记录到它之前就在潜伏，但直到现在你才被诊断出来。至于晚发型，有一些人被描述为童年时期没有 ADHD，但到了成年期才出现。现在，其中几项研究中，成年人是 19、20 岁，这是童年、青春期和成年期之间模糊的诊断界限。在一些追踪儿童的研究案例中
Now, that's different than late identified. Late identified is, yeah, you had the symptoms in childhood, but you got through school okay, maybe underperform, maybe not, but they persisted and caused increased difficulties. Now that you're 21, 25, 35, 55, 55, it's creating impairments so we can document that it was percolating before, but it wasn't until now that you got diagnosed. The late onset, there were individuals who were described as not having ADHD in childhood, but then it's showing up in adulthood. Now, a couple of the studies, the adults were 19, 20, and that's a fuzzy diagnostic line between childhood, adolescence, and adulthood. And in some of the cases of the studies tracking children
到成年期，包括一些童年研究中作为对照组的无 ADHD 儿童，当个体在 20 多岁时出现 ADHD 症状且之前没有时，通常是由于新环境下的正常认知困难，或者是物质使用问题，或者是新出现的抑郁或焦虑障碍。所以通常对所谓的“注意力问题”有另一种解释。就像我喜欢的一句名言：“闪光的不一定都是金子，分心的也不一定都是 ADHD。”因为注意力问题是一个非特异性症状，就像医学实践中的发烧一样。你因为发烧去看家庭医生。
into adulthood, including children without ADHD, who were a control group from some childhood studies, when individuals were showing up in adulthood, in their 20s with ADHD, not having had it before, it was usually normal cognitive difficulties with attention in new circumstances, or maybe substance use problems, or an emergent mood or anxiety disorder. So there was usually another explanation for the quote unquote attention problems. Like one quote, I love, all that glitters is not gold and all that is distracted is not ADHD. It can have, because attention problems are a non-specific symptom, like a fever in medical practice. You go to your family doctor with a fever.
可能是流感，可能是感染，可能是疟疾。你需要更多信息。同样，在注意力问题上，这就是为什么彻底的评估对于验证诊断非常重要。ADHD 对人们的成年生活有什么影响，对他们的人际关系、工作生活甚至身体健康有什么影响？没错。这是一个很好的问题。
Could be the flu. It could be an infection. It could be malaria. You need more information. And likewise, within attention problems, that's why a thorough evaluation is really important to verify the diagnosis. What effects can ADHD have on people's lives in adulthood, on their relationships or their work lives or even their physical health? Right. That's a great question.
而且，你知道，我提到过 ADHD 是神经发育性的。我给出的简要定义是：这是一种自我调节技能的展开和执行受损的神经发育综合征。这些也就是所谓的执行功能，我们每个人都有。它们以相对可预测的模式展开。如果我们今天被闹钟叫醒，那就是你的执行功能在起作用——设置闹钟。如果你把东西放在门口，以免早上出门时忘记，那也是执行功能。几乎没有任何生活领域是不依赖执行功能的。所以，通常促使人们为儿童和青少年寻求评估的原因，
And, you know, I mentioned how ADHD is neurodevelopmental. And my thumbnail definition, it's a neurodevelopmental syndrome of impaired unfolding and execution of self-regulation skills. So these are what are also known as the executive functions, which we all have. And they unfold in a relatively predictable pattern. And these are what, if we wake up to an alarm today, that's your executive functioning, setting an alarm. If you set something by the door so you don't forget it on the way out of out in the morning, that's an executive functioning. There's virtually no area of life in which we don't rely on executive functions. So what generally drives people for an evaluation with children and adolescents,
通常是学校问题，可能还有课堂上的一些行为问题。同样，就像我们在宾大的 ADHD 项目一样，头一两年，有很多大学生。大一或大二，过了适应期后，在没有家庭或高中老师等支柱的情况下，难以独立管理生活。所以这些仍然是困难最突出的地方。但对于成年人来说，它也可能演变成财务困难，比如尽管知道却过度消费，或者不记账、不为退休储蓄等。工作场所、持续的学业、驾驶。而且我们越来越多地看到它对身体健康的影响。
usually school problems and maybe some behavioral problems in the classroom. And similarly for, like with our ADHD program at Penn, our first year or two, it was a lot of college students. First or second year, beyond the adjustment period, having difficulties managing on their own without the scaffolding of home or teachers in high school and whatnot. So those were still where the difficulties were the most prominent. But with adults, it can also turn into financial difficulties, overspending despite knowing or not tracking or not saving for retirement or whatever. Workplace, ongoing academics, driving. and increasingly we're seeing the effects on physical health.
有一项纵向研究追踪了从 8 岁到 20 多岁（27 岁）的儿童。27 岁时的健康状况预测，基于当时的各种行为特征，其预期寿命比同龄人缩短了十多年。现在，这些非常令人沮丧的发现中令人鼓舞的一点是，许多因素是行为性的，可以通过所有针对 ADHD 的循证治疗来针对性解决，并将其作为行为治疗计划的一部分。那么，我们所认为的 ADHD 中的自我调节是什么？即跨越时间组织行为，朝着未来的目标，而不是较小的、即时的回报。
There was one longitudinal study tracking children from eight years old to mid-20s, 27. And the health profiles at 27 years old predicted more than a decades lowered estimated life expectancy at age 27 based on the behavioral profile at that time. Now, one of the encouraging things in these very discouraging findings is, a lot of the elements are behavioral and can be targeted with all the evidence-supported treatments for ADHD and also making it part of a behavioral treatment plan. Then what is self-regulation as we think about it with ADHD, organizing behavior across time towards a future focus, a larger later goal rather than a smaller, sooner payoff.
这就是为什么我们为退休储蓄，但也包括对行为的投资，例如锻炼、注意饮食、坚持药物治疗方案、物理治疗等，但这肯定会影响个人健康。有些人，包括 Russell Barkley，说要把 ADHD 看作一个公共卫生问题。此外，各种人际关系可以被看作是一场耐力赛，包括承诺关系、共同抚养关系，想想作为父母的自我调节需求。成人生活中没有“学年结束”这回事。这是与成年人工作时的一点：你不能重新开始，比如“好吧，新学期，新评分期，新老师”。不，
This is why we save for retirement, but also these investments in behavior, such as exercise, watching diet, follow through with medication regimens, physical therapy, whatever it may be, but it certainly can affect personal health. And some people, including Russell Barkley, have said thinking about ADHD as a public health issue, but also relationships of all sorts are, you can think of them as an endurance race, including committed relationships, co-parenting relationships, and think about the self-regulation demands of being a parent. And there's no end of the school year in adult life. That's one of the things working with adults. You don't get to start, okay, new semester, new marking period, new teacher. No,
它是累积的。因此，人际关系中的困难、互惠性以及在关系中履行责任。这些可能是室友，每个人都必须付房租，但总有人迟交房租。就像我说的，共同抚养的承诺关系，其中存在某种互惠的期望。如果不存在，关系中的归因通常是：如果你在乎我，你就会记得付账单或信守承诺。但我们谈论的是一种神经生物学驱动的综合征，它阻碍了这些事情的发生。话虽如此，我领域里的一句话是：ADHD 不是你的错，但它是你的责任。所以，学校或工作中可以提供一些有用的便利措施，但它们不是无限的。有一些
it's cumulative. And so difficulties within relationships, the reciprocity, and keeping up with responsibilities within a relationship. And these could be roommates where everybody has to pay rent, but somebody's always late with rent. Like I said, a co-parenting committed relationship where there's some expectation of reciprocity. And if it's not there, the attributions often in relationships, if you cared about me, you would remember to pay the bills or keep the promises. But we're talking about a neurobiologically driven syndrome that gets in the way of that happening. Now, that being said, one of the lines in my field is ADHD is not your fault, but it is your responsibility. So there are accommodations that can be helpful at school or at work, but they're not infinite. There's some
措施需要改变应对方式，利用治疗手段，以及其他方法来应对。这可以帮助解决一个人一生中所有潜在的损害领域。你的夏天从家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用特价仅 199 美元的 Nextgrill 四炉头燃气烤架开启夏季烧烤了。整个季节都可以尽情娱乐，Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅仅需 499 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请见 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。
measures that require coping changes, making use of treatments, other things to navigate. That can help with all these domains of potential impairment across somebody's life. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill four-burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season. with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, pricing invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details.
有针对儿童 ADHD 的诊断和治疗指南，但不适用于成年人。这是正确的吗？目前是否需要成人指南？是的。目前，美国 ADHD 及相关疾病专业协会（APSARD）的同事们正在制定第一套美国指南，我是该组织的成员。我没有参与那部分工作，但他们正在审查评估证据。我想你之前的一位嘉宾，也是我非常敬佩的人，Margaret Sibley 博士正在领导
There are guidelines for diagnosing and treating ADHD in children, but they don't apply to adults. Is that correct? And there's a need for adult guidelines at this point. Right. And there are, right now, the first set of U.S. guidelines are being put together by the American Professional Society of ADHD and Related Disorders, colleagues, and I'm a member of that organization. I'm not participating on that side, but they are reviewing the evidence for assessment. And I think one of your previous guests and somebody I admire greatly, Dr. Margaret Sibley is leading
评估审查小组。她也发表了一些精彩的论文，其中一些最终结论我已经在这里提到了，但她有一篇非常好的论文，探讨了首次成人 ADHD 诊断的推荐诊断指南。所以它们已经存在了。我是一个平行小组的成员，该小组隶属于 CHADD（注意力缺陷多动障碍儿童与成人协会），这可能是最大的草根组织，我们将把这些指南转化为针对不同职业的临床工具包，我是团队中的心理学家。
the review team for the assessment. But she's also had some wonderful papers, some of which the final. findings I already mentioned here, but she has a very nice paper looking at the recommended diagnostic guidelines for a first-time adult ADHD diagnosis. So they're out there. And I'm part of a parallel group, a consortium under the rubric of Chad, children and adults with attention deficit hyperactivity disorder, probably the largest grassroots organization, where we're going to take the guidelines and turn them into clinical toolkits for different professions. and I'm the psychologist on the team for that.
但已经有了国际指南，比如欧洲指南、英国的 NICE 指南、澳大利亚指南。这实际上效果很好，因为在美国指南发布一段时间后，其他国家或地区会提出他们的指南，这将是一个迭代的过程。我们已经有了很好的指南，但希望通过美国指南，能更多地关注传播。
But there have been international guidelines, the European guidelines, the nice guidelines in the UK, Australian. And it actually works out well because after the U.S. guidelines are out there for a while, another country, another region will come up with theirs, and it'll be this iterative process. We have good guidelines already, but hopefully with the U.S. guidelines, there'll be more focused on dissemination.
好吧，让我们谈谈治疗。你知道，你有一个治疗成人 ADHD 的临床实践。有哪些治疗方法，包括药物和行为治疗？没错。两种循证治疗方法主要是 ADHD 药物，但不完全是。我不是处方医生，也不是精神科医生。所以我只是在谈论研究和现有方法，也就是说，别起诉我。但主要是兴奋剂药物，尽管也有许多非兴奋剂药物被批准用于成人 ADHD，
Well, let's talk about treatment for a minute. You know, you've got a clinical practice treating adults with ADHD. What kind of treatments are available, both in terms of drugs and behavioral treatments? Right. The two evidence-supported treatments are medications for ADHD predominantly, but not exclusively. And I'm not a prescriber and I'm not a psychiatrist. So I'm just talking about research and what's available, i.e., don't sue me. But predominantly the stimulant medications, even though there are many non-stimulent medications approved for adult ADHD,
针对那些对兴奋剂没有反应或有无法忍受副作用的人。根据荟萃分析，再次声明，我没有从制药公司获得任何资助。对于成年人，基于文献综述的理想起点是苯丙胺类药物。而对于儿童和青少年，起点似乎是哌甲酯类药物。在心理社会治疗方面，认知行为疗法（CBT）已成为循证治疗方法。尽管 ADHD 终身诊断带来的一些生活结果很可怕，有各种损害，并不是每个人都有所有症状，但几乎没有任何成人生活领域能躲过 ADHD。它可以影响任何领域，正如我所说，驾驶以及其他许多事情。但这也是临床精神病学和心理学中最有效的治疗方法之一，
for people who don't respond to the stimulants or have intolerable side effects. And based on meta-analyses, and again, I get no funding from pharmaceutical companies. For adults, the ideal starting points based on the literature reviews is the amphetamine-based. And for children and teens, it seems to be the methylphenidate-based medications, at least as a starting point. And then in terms of psychosocial treatment therapy, the cognitive behavioral therapy has emerged as the evidence supported treatment. And as dire as some of the life outcomes of a lifetime diagnosis of ADHD, of different impairments, not everybody has everything, but there's virtually no area of adult life that can hide from ADHD. It can affect any, like I said, driving a whole host of other things. but there's also some of the most effective treatments that we have in all clinical psychiatry and psychology,
包括药物组合。所以有很多选择。同样，有很多优秀的认知行为治疗师。然而，并非所有人，或者说得委婉点，他们中没有多少人有直接治疗成人 ADHD 的经验。事实上，英国在过去几个月里有一项研究调查了客户体验，即接受成人 ADHD 的认知行为疗法。完成问卷调查后，少数人接受了采访。初步阅读结果很糟糕，因为客户说这似乎
including the combination of medications. So there's a lot of options out there. Again, there's a lot of great cognitive behavioral therapists. However, not all of them, or maybe qualify that, not many of them have had direct experience with adult ADHD. In fact, there was a study in the UK within the past several months looking at client experience, is going through cognitive behavioral therapy for adult ADHD. Completing questionnaires and a handful got interviewed afterwards. And the initial reading of the results were awful because clients were saying it didn't seem
我的治疗师不了解 ADHD，也不了解 ADHD 患者面临的困难。所以这是许多客户的抱怨。现在，其中一位受访者报告说，他们的治疗师非常精通 ADHD 和成人 ADHD，并将治疗描述为“变革性的”。“我感到被理解，我觉得我可以理解我的大脑并与它合作，而不是对抗它”，并感到他们取得了很大进步。现在，这是两种循证治疗方法。还有许多其他方法可能有一些研究支持，比如一些基于正念的
my therapist understood ADHD or understood the difficulties folks with ADHD have. So that was the complaints of many clients. Now, one of the interviewees reported that their therapist was very versed in ADHD and adult ADHD, and describe treatment as transformative. I felt understood, and I felt I could understand my brain and work with it rather than against it and felt they made a lot of progress. Now, those are the two evidence-based treatments. There are a host of others that maybe have some studies behind them, like some mindfulness-based
针对 ADHD 的小组，专门为成人 ADHD 调整过。ADHD 教练是另一种。它已经存在大约 25 年了。它最初是《分心不是我的错》（Driven to Distraction）一书中的一个隐喻，Ned Hallowell 和 John Rady 说过类似的话：成人 ADHD 患者需要的是一种类似于教练的东西，可以帮助他们保持进度并实施技能。于是它变成了 ADHD 教练，有一些非常好的培训项目，但它还不是一个持牌职业，但它确实有一些实证研究。所以它仍在收集研究数据。但我提到过，
groups for ADHD, adapted for adult ADHD. ADHD coaching is another one. It's been around for about 25 years now. it started off as a metaphor in the book Driven to Distraction, where Ned Hallowell and John Rady said something like, what adults with ADHD is something akin to a coach that can help them keep on track and implement skills. And so it became this ADHD coaching, and there are some very good training programs, but it is not a licensed profession yet, but it does have some empirical research. So it's still gathering research. But I mentioned,
教练类比人们需要实施方面的帮助，我认为这是对 ADHD 的一个重要描述，尤其是对成年人而言。这不是一个知识问题，而是一个执行问题。不是不知道你应该早点开始完成任务，或者你应该准时，或者类似的事情。人们知道这些，但很难付诸实践。那个患有最严重 ADHD 的七岁孩子知道他应该举手等待被点名，但在那一刻，“我知道答案。我知道《独立宣言》并非全部在 7 月 4 日签署，但它是什么时候签署的？1776 年 7 月 4 日”，然后手就举起来了。这就是顺序问题。他们知道，但它并没有以我们
how the coach analogy that people need help with implementation, I think that's an important description of ADHD across the board, but especially for adults. It is not a knowledge problem. It's a performance problem. It's not knowing that you should start earlier to get things done or that you should be on time or anything like that. People know that, but it's difficulty putting it into play. The seven-year-old with the worst ADHD knows they should raise their hand and wait to be called on, but in the moment, I know the answer. I know the Declaration of Independence was not all signed on July 4th, but when was it signed? July 4th, 1776, and then the arm goes up. It's the sequencing. They know it, but it doesn't manifest in the way
需要的方式表现出来。现在这是一个非常无辜的例子，但后来在成年期。我见过有人错过工作面试、挂科，不是因为他们考试考得不好，而是因为他们没有交作业，或者违反了出勤政策，尽管工作质量很好。这就是 ADHD 的阴险本质，它如何破坏这些事情，包括我提到的在人际关系中，你是一个很棒的人，我信任你，但我不能信任你会按时付账单，或者你不会出去过度消费等等。
we need it to. Now that's a very innocent example, but then later on in adulthood. And I've had people miss job interviews failing a class, not because they didn't do well on the test, but because they didn't hand in assignments or they violated the attendance policy, even though the quality of the work is good. And that's the insidious nature of ADHD, how it can undermine these things, including, as I mentioned in relationships, you're a great person. I trust you, but I can't trust that you'll pay the bills on time or that you won't go out and overspend or things like that.
这就是破坏承诺关系的原因。那么在这种情况下，教练是如何工作的呢？因为听起来患有此病的成年人需要不断的提醒。这不是像每周或每两周见一次治疗师并接受指导那样。那么你如何每天得到那种小小的推动力呢？嗯，你知道吗？在一些 CBT 研究中，现在这已被纳入研究。有一些方法可以增加每周的疗程，比如每隔几天打个电话检查作业。一些老派的治疗方法可能会说，嗯，你不应该那样做。
And that's what kind of even erode committed relationships. So how would coaching in this instance work? Because it sounds like people, adults who have this, need like a constant reminder. It's not like once a week or every two weeks you can see your therapist and get coached there. So how do you on a daily basis get that little impetus? Well, you know what? Within some studies of CBT, now this is worked into studies. There have been some approaches where they would augment the weekly sessions and maybe having calls in between, like every couple days to check on homework. And some old school therapy approaches might say, well, you don't do that.
但如果疗程之间有作业总结，或者邀请人们在需要时进行核对，比如核对他们在我的治疗中正在做的事情，或者安排更频繁的疗程。现在，在 ADHD 教练领域，不一定是每天，但他们可能会设置更频繁的电话核对，甚至是一些实地考察，如果有人正在处理组织工作的话。现在，再次强调，这就是 ADHD 教练存在已久的原因。在疫情之前就有远程疗程。那是后续短信、电话的一部分。
But if there's between session summary of the homework assignments or inviting people to check in, if they need to double check like what they're working on within my therapy with them or scheduling more frequent sessions. Now, within the field of ADHD coaching, it's not necessarily every day, but they might set up more frequent phone check-ins or even things. things like site visits, if somebody's working on an organization. Now, again, this is where ADHD coaching has been around for a while. It had remote sessions before the pandemic. That was part of follow-up text, phone calls.
所以他们要灵活得多。在教练培训方面，关于培训期望和你能得到的质量差异很大，因为它的控制不如，比如说，我带有偏见，但不如临床心理学的研究生课程，然后是博士后培训和执照。但它确实有立足点，我认为它填补了一个空白，即认知行为治疗师或其他心理学家等，没有那么多可用。而 ADHD 教练，这就是为它设计的。他们接受过 ADHD 培训。对于大多数成年人来说，最有效的治疗方法是
So they were much more agile. And in terms of training of coaches, there are some things about sort of training expectations and the wide variety of quality you can get because it doesn't have the same controls as, say, and I'm biased, but like a graduate program in clinical psychology and then the postdoctoral training and the licensing. But it does have a foothold, and I think it filled a need where the cognitive behavioral therapist or other psychologists or whatnot, there weren't as many of them available. Whereas ADHD, that's what it's designed for. They get trained in ADHD. And for most adults, I mean, there's the most effective treatment,
CBT 或某种疗法与药物的结合，还是你可以只做其中一种？这是自我决定的权利。所以有时个人出于各种原因，但总体而言，似乎结合治疗是最好的。事实上，最近有研究探讨了药物如何对核心症状非常有帮助。注意力、运动性多动和冲动、躁动、持续专注。但你可以非常专注却在别的事情上拖延，或者组织混乱但非常专注。这就是心理社会治疗，我会说认知行为疗法可以
a combination of either CBT or some kind of therapy and drugs, or can you do just one or the other? Right of self-determination. So sometimes individual for various reasons, but overall, it seems like the combined is the best. And actually, there's recent research looking at how the medications are very helpful with the core symptoms. The attention, the motoric hyperactivity, and impulsivity, a restlessness, sustained focus. But you can focus really well and procrastinate on something else or be disorganized, but well-focused. And that's where the psychosocial treatments, I'll say the cognitive behavioral therapy can
发挥作用的地方。此外，还有执行功能的应对技能。但这里有几点。第一，带着 ADHD 生活一生会导致一些负面的自我信念和负面认知，因为 ADHD 成年人的经历，特别是如果直到成年才被诊断出来，通常是：“你是说我并不笨、懒或疯？”这是关于 ADHD 的第一本畅销书之一，但我认为它引起了我的共鸣，我之所以一直
come in. And also with that, the executive functioning coping skills. But a couple things there. One, living with a lifetime of ADHD can lead to some negative self-beliefs and negative cognitions because very often the experience of adults with ADHD having lived with it, particularly if it's gone undiagnosed to adulthood, is, you mean I'm not stupid, lazy, or crazy. That was one of the first popular books on ADHD, but I think it resonates me and why I keep
引用它，是因为那会是心态。“我怎么了？”这是一种神经发育综合征，而且 DSM 标准中没有显示的一点是，我们现在正在认识到，执行功能之一是情绪自我调节，情绪是 ADHD 情绪自我调节的一部分。有两个因素，即情绪冲动，情绪不受控制地涌现。没有那种最初的减速来说，“哇，哇，发生了什么？”它来得很快，然后更难有效地平复它。
citing it is because that would be the mindset. What's wrong with me? And it is a neurodevelopmental syndrome, as well as one of the things that doesn't show up in the DSM criteria, but we're now appreciating, and one of the executive functions is emotional self-regulation, that emotions, the emotional piece of ADHD is part of the self-regulation. There's two factors, it's emotional impulsivity, the emotions come on unchecked. There's not that initial slowdown to say, whoa, whoa, what am I what's going on here? it comes on quick and then it's harder to soothe it as efficiently.
所以那种情绪冲动，然后是情绪自我调节不足，这是我们通常使用的第二层。这两者都是有问题的。甚至回到 1970 年代，Paul Wender，ADHD 的早期专家之一，也是较早识别成人 ADHD 的专业人士之一，当时就指出了情绪的作用，包括挫折耐受力差、容易发怒。而且他已经去世了，但由 Fred Reimer 领导的团队最近确定了一个 ADHD 的双因素模型。一个是注意力不集中，主要是注意力不集中型。但第二个是情绪自我调节。现在，它仅基于该小组的一两项研究，但其他小组已经证明了情绪的相关性。这些与……是分开的，这是治疗的另一部分，以及心理社会治疗和药物如何协同工作。
So that emotional impulsivity, then the deficient emotional self-regulation is the second layer we typically use. Those are both problematic. And even going back to the 1970s, Paul Wender, one of the early experts in ADHD and one of the earlier professionals who identified adult ADHD, both at the time identified the role of emotions, including poor frustration tolerance, quick to anger. And also he's since passed away, but his group headed by Fred Reimer recently identified a two-factor model of ADHD. One was inattention, predominantly inattentive. But the second was emotional self-regulation. Now, it's only based on one or two studies by that group, but other groups have shown the relevance of emotions. And these are separate from the, and this is another part of treatment and how psychosocial and medications can work alongside each other.
共病是成人 ADHD 的常态而非例外。前两位是焦虑和抑郁。焦虑，我写过关于焦虑的工作手册，焦虑的特征之一是除了对风险的感知外，还包括对不确定性的不耐受。在我看来，ADHD 是一个不确定性发生器。现在，有些人会进行个体治疗。他们可能只靠药物就做得很好。
And comorbidity is the rule rather than the exception for adult ADHD. The top two being anxiety and depression. And anxiety, and I did the workbook on anxiety, one of the features of anxiety is the intolerance of uncertainty in addition to the perception of risk. And for my money, ADHD is an uncertainty generator. Now, some people will do individual treatments. They might do fine just on medications. and with that they're able to say, okay, now I can be on time, use my plan or whatever.
有了药物，他们能够说，“好吧，现在我可以准时了，使用我的计划表或任何东西。”我见过只做 CBT 的人，可能有一些罕见的医疗状况不允许他们服用 ADHD 药物，或者副作用无法忍受，或者是孕妇或哺乳期妇女。现在，一些关于药物和怀孕的研究结论不一，但通常处方医生和个人可能会谨慎行事，尽管它不是
And I've seen people individually for just CBT, there may be like a rare medical condition that does not allow them to take ADHD medications or that the side effects are intolerable or a pregnant woman or breastfeeding woman. Now, some of the research on medications and pregnancy are equivocal, but usually prescribers and individuals might err on the side of caution, even though it's not. a blanket prohibition, but people just being cautious. Or there might be people say, you know, I want to try it without medications first. And right of self-determination, I always invite it as an option, but it's just pretty much doubling down on the, on the CBT and the implementation-focused
全面禁止，但人们只是保持谨慎。或者有些人说，“你知道，我想先尝试不吃药。”这是自我决定的权利，我总是把它作为一个选项，但这基本上是在加倍投入 CBT 和以实施为重点的
interventions. You know, I read about a recent survey out of Ohio State University that found that 25% of U.S. adults think they have undiagnosed ADHD. Right. The research is speculated that part of the reason might be the popularity of ADHD-related content on social media. What's your take on this self-diagnosis? Is this really a thing or people just reading so much about it and they think they've got it? I think it's part of all of them.
干预措施。你知道，我读到俄亥俄州立大学最近的一项调查发现，25% 的美国成年人认为自己患有未确诊的 ADHD。没错。研究推测，部分原因可能是社交媒体上与 ADHD 相关内容的流行。你对这种自我诊断有什么看法？这真的是一回事，还是人们只是读了太多关于它的东西，然后认为自己得了？我认为这部分原因都有。
So it's out there. And in a way, it's the part of the career. direction. So 10 years ago, ADHD would be the last thing after everything else got tried. And okay, maybe it's that. Or maybe individuals brought it up. And the provider might say, I say this respectfully, might be going, why not check it out? We got nothing to lose. So some of it is now it's out there in the language and the culture a little more, especially over the pandemic, and maybe on a shorter list of possibilities. Because one of the things about the symptoms of ADHD and the executive functions, they're a dimensional human trait where something like, say, bipolar disorder,
所以它就在那里。在某种程度上，这是“纠偏”的一部分。所以 10 年前，ADHD 会是在尝试了其他一切之后才考虑的最后一件事。或者，也许是个人提出来的。提供者可能会说——我这是出于尊重——可能会想：“为什么不检查一下呢？我们没什么可损失的。”所以其中一部分是现在它在语言和文化中更多地存在了，特别是在疫情期间，也许在可能性清单上排得更靠前了。因为关于 ADHD 症状和执行功能的一点是，它们是一种维度性的人类特质，而像双相情感障碍那样，
where it has very clear onset. And we could say it's a qualitative difference from, say, the typical range of mood most of us experience. But ADHD feels familiar for a lot of people. Oh, yeah, I do that sometimes. I almost left my iPad on the plane the other day, or I lose focus, which is true. I think like I said before, you get the flu, your executive functioning will go down. You have a bout of insomnia. Your executive functioning will go down. But if you don't have ADHD, as these situations, conditions remit spontaneously or with treatment, your executive function will go back to a baseline. It's normative baseline. With ADHD, the baseline is a moving target. So there was a study of children, and it was a population study. So many of them did not
它有非常清晰的发作。我们可以说它与我们大多数人经历的典型情绪范围有质的区别。但 ADHD 对很多人来说感觉很熟悉。“哦，是的，我有时也会那样。”我前几天差点把 iPad 落在飞机上，或者我失去了专注力，这是真的。我想就像我之前说的，你得了流感，你的执行功能就会下降。你失眠了，你的执行功能就会下降。但如果你没有 ADHD，随着这些情况或条件自发缓解或通过治疗缓解，你的执行功能会回到基线。这是规范的基线。对于 ADHD，基线是一个移动的目标。所以有一项针对儿童的研究，这是一项人口研究。所以他们中许多人并没有
have ADHD. A handful of them screened positive for ADHD as part of this study. And another group had been identified as already diagnosed. So what this study did, it was all parent ratings. Rate your child using this 18 item ADHD rating scale and also rate their quality of life, pretty much a functioning schedule. So, parents rating their children with zero or one symptom of ADHD. Very high well-being ratings. They're doing well. Two or three, really well.
患有 ADHD。其中少数人在这项研究中筛查出 ADHD 阳性。另一组已经被识别为已确诊。所以这项研究做的是，全是家长的评分。使用这个 18 项 ADHD 评分量表来评价你的孩子，并评价他们的生活质量，基本上是一个功能表。所以，家长评价他们的孩子有 0 或 1 个 ADHD 症状。幸福感评分非常高。他们做得很好。2 或 3 个，非常好。
Maybe a smidge less well. Six, seven, eight out of 18, nine. Probably not diagnostic levels, but the ratings start, the well-being ratings start going down. But maybe not diagnosed with ADHD. And then we get up into the diagnostic levels, you know, 10, left 12, 13, 14, 18, the well-being ratings go steadily down. Now, there's a lot of variation. It's not a one-to-one. But the trend was the more symptoms of ADHD you had, at least rated by your parents, the lower your well-being.
也许稍微没那么好。18项里有六、七、八或九项符合。可能还没达到诊断标准，但幸福感评分开始下降。不过可能还没被诊断为多动症（ADHD）。当我们达到诊断水平时，比如10、12、13、14、18项，幸福感评分会稳步下降。当然，个体差异很大，并非一一对应。但趋势是，你表现出的多动症症状越多（至少是根据你父母的评价），你的幸福感就越低。
So my take on the Ohio State survey, the 25% guessing, I would say maybe a lot of those people, maybe they fall in that middle sub-threat. threshold range where somebody goes, yeah, I have insomnia every couple weeks for a day or two, but I don't need a sleep study or whatever. And sometimes I've really stressed out and I'm not as well, but I usually rebound and I don't have the time or money or to go see this Ramsey guy or anybody else. But there might be like the two or three or four or five out of those where they self-diagnosed, say, or at least self-screen. And I think self-diagnosis gets a bad rap because Now, somebody could go and say, oh, I must have ADHD then, because TikTok told me I do. And there was a study saying pretty much in a nutshell, 80% of TikTok content is unreliable, if not patently wrong.
所以我对俄亥俄州立大学那项调查中25%的猜测是，我想其中很多人可能处于中间的阈值范围，有人会说，是的，我每隔几周就会失眠一两天，但我不需要做睡眠研究之类的。有时我确实压力很大，状态不好，但我通常能恢复，而且我没有时间或金钱去看拉姆齐医生或其他人。但其中可能有两、三、四或五个人是自我诊断的，或者至少是自我筛查的。我认为自我诊断名声不好，因为现在有人可能会去说，哦，那我一定有ADHD，因为TikTok告诉我有。有一项研究简而言之指出，80%的TikTok内容是不可靠的，甚至完全是错误的。
But the most influential posts are personal stories. So even if they're wrong, they are compelling and believable. So there's a lot of misinformation, but the self-screening, the self-diagnosis, if that's followed up with, well, let me go get an evaluation that is familiar with ADHD and follows, like, for right now, Maggie Sibley's advice, which will probably turn into a nice skeleton framework for the guidelines, as well as looking for things that could better explain what you think are ADHD. And I know some of my, the evaluations I'm most fond of are the ones where I was able to sit with somebody and say, yeah, you're rating the high on the ADHD scales, but here's a better explanation for what's going on. Because that's, you know, as practicing clinicians, that's what we're looking for. Is it depression? Is it anxiety?
但最有影响力的帖子是个人故事。所以即使它们是错的，它们也很有吸引力且令人信服。所以有很多错误信息，但自我筛查和自我诊断，如果后续能跟进，比如，让我去接受一个熟悉ADHD并遵循指导的评估，就像现在玛吉·西布利的建议那样，这可能会成为指南的一个很好的框架，同时也要寻找能更好地解释你认为的ADHD症状的其他原因。我知道我最喜欢的一些评估是那些我能坐下来和某人说，是的，你在ADHD量表上得分很高，但这里有对当前情况更好的解释。因为作为执业临床医生，这就是我们要寻找的。是抑郁症吗？是焦虑症吗？
Is it trauma? Is it OCD and substance use and running through everything? And it might sound like, oh, my gosh, this is going to be like an eight-hour evaluation. Well, no, if you go through and you know, what you're doing, and I do a skid. So if you know the skip-out questions on the skid and you get two nose in a row, it's like barring other information to the contrary. You can move on and be relatively efficient. So finally, for our listeners who may be among the 25 percent of people wondering if they have it, how do you decide if it's worth getting tested and where should you go? You know what?
是创伤吗？是强迫症还是药物滥用？我们要排查所有可能。这听起来可能像，天哪，这得是一个八小时的评估。嗯，不，如果你知道自己在做什么，并且我做过结构化临床访谈（SCID）。所以如果你知道SCID中的跳过问题，并且连续得到两个否定回答，那么在没有相反信息的情况下，你可以继续进行，效率相对较高。所以最后，对于我们那些可能属于那25%想知道自己是否有ADHD的听众，你如何决定是否值得去测试，以及你应该去哪里？你知道吗？
A readily available, reputable screening scale that is available for free is the World Health organization adult ADHD symptom rating scale. And it's available with a quick internet search. And you can download it at six items. Now, like any screening scale, like for diabetes or heart disease or depression, anything like that, screening scales cast a wide net because you want to catch the true positives. And you'll put up with a couple of false positives in there for follow-up evaluation. So that would be a way to screen. If you're in a relationship or, you know, somebody you're comfortable asking and say, yeah, I wonder if I have ADHD and seeing what somebody else says. And I've had people say, other people who said to them, oh, I thought you knew already or
一个现成、可靠且免费的筛查量表是世界卫生组织的成人ADHD症状自评量表。通过快速网络搜索就能找到。你可以下载它，只有六个项目。现在，像任何筛查量表一样，无论是针对糖尿病、心脏病还是抑郁症，筛查量表覆盖面很广，因为你想捕捉到真正的阳性病例。你会容忍其中出现几个假阳性，以便进行后续评估。所以这是一种筛查方式。如果你处于一段关系中，或者有你可以放心询问的人，你可以说，是的，我想知道我是否有ADHD，看看别人的看法。我曾听人说，其他人对他们说，哦，我还以为你早就知道了，或者
something like that. Or I'm glad you brought that up in early. I was wondering about that too, but I didn't want to hurt your feelings or whatever. So that is a starting point. In terms of where do you go to find somebody, the main professional organizations, Chad, children and adults with ADHD, The Attention Deficit Disorder Association, that one focuses specifically on adults. They will have find a helper, find a professional, find a therapist features on their websites. Absard, I'm not sure. I don't think they have a find a professional yet because it is more of a professional organization. But here's advice I've been giving people looking.
类似的话。或者说，很高兴你提到了，我之前也想过这个问题，但我不想伤害你的感情之类的。所以这是一个起点。至于去哪里找人，主要的专业组织，如CHADD（多动症儿童与成人协会）、ADDA（注意力缺陷障碍协会），后者专门针对成人。他们的网站上有“寻找帮助者”、“寻找专业人士”、“寻找治疗师”的功能。对于APSARD，我不确定。我不认为他们有“寻找专业人士”的功能，因为它更像是一个专业组织。但我一直给人们的建议是：
If they're from a state, I'm not, I don't know anybody in or other region. I say look at the board of directors or the professional advisory boards of the ADHD organizations and see what the academic affiliations are and maybe reach out to people to say, oh, I see you're at the University of Wherever. Do you know of any referrals in the state or nearby or things like that? So it's a little bit of a six degrees of separation approach to getting there. But authors of books, I think Ned Hallowell, many of his books, he'll have lists in the back of people he knows. who provide services. I know in a couple of my books, I had some listing of colleagues who had
如果他们来自某个州，或者我不认识任何人的地区。我会说看看ADHD组织的董事会或专业咨询委员会，看看他们的学术背景，也许可以联系他们说，哦，我看到你在某某大学。你知道在这个州或附近有什么推荐的医生吗？所以这是一种“六度分隔”的方法。但书籍作者，我认为内德·哈洛韦尔，他的许多书后面都有他认识的提供服务的人的名单。我知道在我的一些书中，我也列出了一些同事，他们有
programs around. But one of things professionally and personally, my experience has been the ADHD community, the adult ADHD community has been very giving, like in terms of, oh, can I use your questionnaire and my evaluations and giving within professionals and wanting to make sure people get the help they need. And I think the forthcoming U.S. guidelines are an expression of that a love letter to adults with ADHD in a way in the U.S. hopefully. Well, Dr. Ramsey, I want to thank you for joining me today. This is a lot of useful information. Thank you. Kim, it was a pleasure and it was honored to be asked.
相关的项目。但从专业和个人角度来看，我的经验是ADHD社区，成人ADHD社区非常慷慨，比如在“我可以用你的问卷和评估吗”方面，专业人士之间非常乐于分享，并确保人们得到他们需要的帮助。我认为即将出台的美国指南就是这种精神的体现，在某种程度上是给美国成人ADHD患者的一封情书。好吧，拉姆齐医生，感谢您今天加入我的节目。这些信息非常有用。谢谢。金，很高兴能受邀参加。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. For those of you who want to know more about psychology and the work of APA, you can join us as a supporter. You don't have to be a psychologist. The benefits include a subscription to our award-winning magazine, monitor on psychology, as well as discounts on our books and other publications. So if psychology is your passion, or you just want to know more about the science, you can become a supporter by visiting at.a.a.org slash speaking. That's at.a.a.org
您可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Spotify、YouTube或任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的内容，请订阅并留下评论。对于那些想了解更多关于心理学和美国心理学会（APA）工作的人，您可以加入我们成为支持者。您不必是心理学家。福利包括订阅我们屡获殊荣的杂志《心理学监测》，以及购买我们的书籍和其他出版物的折扣。所以，如果心理学是您的热情所在，或者您只是想了解更多科学知识，您可以访问at.apa.org/speaking成为支持者。那是at.apa.org
slash speaking. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items, then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes, so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
slash speaking。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，请发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼制作。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。放松一下，让Ralph's的配送服务来处理您本周的杂货采购。我们从最新鲜的商品开始，然后查看您的清单并仔细挑选每一件。然后我们打包好并在短短30分钟内送达，让您确信这就是您订购的商品。新鲜杂货，随心所欲，尽在Ralph's配送和自提服务。现在，您的首单配送或自提订单可立减20美元。Ralph's，让每个人都享受新鲜。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。